three years on and the pain is clear to
see
mourners gather beneath the shrouded
shell of grim fell tower but this time
most are forced to keep their distance
due to covert 19 Nabil Shakir lost six
family members including his mother and
sister that night and relied on his
friend Tariq to take flowers to the
scene unable to bear returning for the
anniversary it's more than he'll I'm not
coping I'm just trying to get on and get
my and it's very hard you just have to
keep fighting every day is another day
kind of thing and just keep fighting
looking to do something for the innocent
people that was this year there will be
no silent March to mark the loss of
seventy two lives instead there was a
virtual church service the hoardings
here at the foot of grenfell tower
remain a focal point for people to write
messages and leave tributes but for the
bereaved there's a private place to
bring their flowers and the opportunity
to have those flowers then taken up to
their loved ones flat the government
says it's allocated a billion pounds to
remove the kind of dangerous cladding
from other blocks but calls the flames
to spread at Grenfell but kareem muscle
he says it should be happening faster
his uncle died on the top floor we've
uncovered a completely and utter rot in
industry and we're talking thousands of
buildings across the country we're
talking tens of thousands of people
stuck in these unsafe death traps and I
don't feel like this government has come
to grips with the urgency of the
situation
at 6:00 p.m. bells tolled in churches
across the capital and beyond for each
of the lives lost then two minutes
silence
[Music]
hello mr. Dell here I want to send my
love to all of you today and I'm
thinking of you as I always do and at
the same time a tribute video appeared
online including this message from the
singer Adele a supporter of the families
from the start its purpose to urge
people not just to remember but to keep
pushing for justice the inquiry into the
cause of the tragedy was suspended in
March due to the pandemic is left those
who lost friends and family still
waiting for answers
EMA Birchley Sky News West London